Partout dans le monde,
nous sommes des milliers à refuser de subir les crises
et la barbarie de cette société capitaliste.
Dans les manifestations de solidarité
avec le peuple palestinien
ou ceux d'en bas défilent
contre les massacres et la guerre
voulue par ce don,
dans les grèves pour les salaires
dans l'automobile aux États-Unis
ou dans le textile au Bangladesh
où les ouvriers luttent face à leurs placements
vertigineuses,
dans les manifs contre le changement climatique,
il y a toute 1 jeunesse qui se soulève pour remplacer,
euh, les petits gestes par l'élutte collective,
dans les mouvements féministes
où les femmes refusent de voir le droit à l'avortement
remis en cause,
où les violences sexistes se poursuivent
en toute impunité.
Partout la révolte fleuriste, partout la misère augmente,
mais pas pour tous.
Ce malheur de l'humanité permet au profit
de couler 1 flot,
aux actionnaires d'encaisser des divisions
toujours plus indécents.
Plus que jamais, il faut changer le monde,
construire 1 autre société,
1 société débarrassée du profit et de l'exploitation,
1 société débarrassée des guerres impérials,
faite avec la peau des peuples.
Pour faire cette révolution
capable de renverser tout l'ordre capitaliste,
nous avons besoin de tous et nous avons besoin de vous.
Depuis des années,
dans les luttes comme dans les élections,
le npa porte 1 voie radicale,
anticapitaliste,
révolutionnaire,
communiste, internationalliste.
Dernièrement, nous avons bravé avec d'autres
l'interdiction de
manifester 1 soutien au peuple palestinien
et avons obtenu la levée de ses interdictions,
comme beaucoup d'entre Vous,
étions dans la rue pour participer au mouvement massif
d'une durée exceptionnelle
contre la réforme de retraite
et contre Macron.
Nous militons au quotidien, dans les entreprises,
dans la jeunesse, pour construire les mobilisations,
pour exister et développer cette intervention militante.
Nous ne bénéficions d'aucun financement de l'état,
aucun compte plan qui est en Suisse.
Seule les cotisations de nos militants
et les dons de solidarité
nous permettent de militer.
Alors faut que cette voie continue à se faire entendre.
Nous avons besoin de vous,
nous avons besoin de vous !
Nous avons lancé 1 grande campagne de souscription
dans le but d'obtenir 1.000.000 d'euros.
Les dons de chacun d'entre vous
seront déterminants pour atteindre cet objectif.
Alors donnez au npa,
parlez-en autour de vous,
à vos proches, en famille,
pour que notre organisation continue à exister.
Apportez le combat pour 1 autre société !